a g7 summit in Paris has ended and there
were some surprises there including US
president on a Trump sharing a fun press
conference with German Chancellor Angela
Merkel and talks of a possible US UK
trade deal now one that could help
offset the economic damage of a No Deal
breaks it at least that is what British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson has been
touting lately but not so fast the US
Congress has a say on every trade deal
and many Congress members fear that a No
Deal brexit would return new controls to
the Irish border undermining the 1998
Good Friday peace agreement which ended
30 years of violence between the two
sides the top Democrat Nancy Pelosi says
that a trade deal has quote no chance
whatsoever with a border congressman
Richard Neal is co-chair of the Friends
of Ireland caucus which counts 50 for
Congress members and he's no fan either
and there is also top Republican Peter
King an ally of President on a Trump and
he called talks of a deal a needless
provocation so there is strong
bipartisan support in Congress for the
Good Friday Agreement and to learn a
little bit more about this possible
dilemma I'm joined by Arthur Sullivan
from DW business good to have you here
with us Arthur I know that you've really
looked into this entire story do you
think that the Good Friday Agreement
could really stand in the way of a US UK
trade deal yeah well yes Monica I
certainly think it could stand in the
way I suppose a little bit of history as
a starting point so there's a very
strong history of strong relations
between ireland america and particularly
in the political dimension there's a
very strong irish american lobby group
political caucus that dates back more
than a century and at various stages of
irish history it's been very influential
but for the purposes of our discussion
where it's really important is in the
crafting of what you mentioned just now
the Good Friday Agreement so the Clinton
administration were absolutely critical
in that very important piece d have been
struck and as a result of that there is
a deep understanding within large
sections of the US Congress of how
important the Good Friday Agreement
is in Ireland and also how important the
Irish border and keeping that border
open is to maintaining that peace
agreement so the reason why it could as
you say stand in the way of a possible
UK u.s. free trade deal is simply
because they've said it several US
politicians have said it the third most
senior US politician Nancy Pelosi has
said it several times this year back in
April she visited the Irish border she
went to the city of Derry and she spoke
in absolutely unambiguous terms and said
that if there is any disruption
whatsoever to the current border
situation in Ireland as a result of a
chaotic no deal brags or any form of
brags at which would change those
arrangements she said there's no chance
whatsoever and then on top of that you
have to look at other areas of US
political life so what you mentioned the
Friends of Ireland caucus that's led by
some very influential US politicians
Richard Neil whom you mentioned and a
very important point on Richard Neil
Richard Neil is the head of the US House
Ways and Means Committee know the House
Ways and Means Committee has a direct
say in trade deals they can block their
deals and before it even gets to the
Senate they have to look at it and
scrutinize that they have to the first
port of call in that sort of speed okay
so that could be an awful lot of hurdles
coming in the way of a US UK trade deal
but there is a possible solution and
that is called the backstop which is
part of the withdrawal agreement that
Boris Johnson and the government in
London is turning down why well I
suppose it's first of all important to
say that it's not everyone in Britain
who's against the backstop but I mean
Boris Johnson himself voted for the most
recent version of the withdrawal
agreement which included the backstop
but there is consistent opposition
within Britain to the backstop and to
put it simply the reason they oppose it
is some of the more ardent brags eaters
believe that the backstop could keep
Britain indefinitely in legal limbo with
the EU
so as the backstop is currently phrased
it would keep the whole of the UK in a
customs union with the rest of the EU
until a solution has been agreed which
would would change the arrangement would
maintain the range London isn't so keen
on that so right now the UK there sits
between a rock and a hard chair talk
about Boris Johnson because he also said
that his government might not pay the so
called divorce bill at least not in full
if Britain was to leave the EU without a
deal the European mission how
points out that a failure to pay could
hamper future trade negotiations but
listen in all commitments that were
taken by the 28 member states should be
honored and this is also and especially
true in an audio scenario where the
United Kingdom would be expected to
continue to honor all commitments made
during a you membership rather than
going now into a judicial action threat
I think that it is important to make
clear that settling accounts is
essential to starting off a new
relationship on the right foot based on
mutual trust and I would also say that
as far as I understand this issue has
not been raced with the EU side for the
time being officially all right EU
Commission there on the possibility that
the UK does not pay the divorce bill
let's bring in a financial market
correspondent Ashutosh Pandey on this
why not paying your bills doesn't go
down well with anyone how much money are
we talking about and what would it mean
for the EU well Monica it's a 39 billion
pounds that both sides of a Blee two or
forty three billion euros this is
largely the money that UK owes to the
illu the committe financial commitments
that it has made as far as the budget is
concerned future projects are concerned
even pension for staff pensions are
concerned so that's a payment that both
sides have actually agreed upon now as
far as you or the user ability to
compensate for this loss is concerned it
certainly can I mean at the end of the
day 39 billion pounds is a huge amount
of money but not enough to [ __ ] the
--use economy it will have to cut some
funding for long-term projects or call
on richer members to actually bridge the
gap but the bigger loss would be
actually the loss of trust with a key
trading partner all right I should just
thank you so much last question to
author there so for the UK runs the risk
of losing a friend what what other
implications could there be for the
United Kingdom well the really big
implication is the one that Ashutosh
just touched on so in the event of them
not paying that bail which to use as
their existing commitments it would
jeopardize the prospects of a few
trade deal with the EU because the EU
have said if they don't pay that bill
we're not talking about trade the UK can
talk all it wants about doing a trade
deal with the US but the fact remains
its biggest trading partner is the rest
of the EU so if there's no trade deal
with the rest of the EU then that was
seriously hampered the UK's economy and
then the other point is what would this
do to the UK's goodwill on the
international stage if they don't pay
existing bills why should other
countries get involved with them and
trade deals or the negotiations because
it would damage their standing which at
the moment is still quite high despite
everything that's happened with brags it
all right Arthur Sullivan there from DW
business thank you so much for your
insights there and also big thank you to
our show - Monday in Frankfurt